so welcome to day two of ilc although it
feels like we're already halfway through
the day so uh really really excited
about this day yesterday we had a sneak
peek into the exciting future of the
company uh thank you so much for all of
your engagement uh the excitement was
really palpable throughout the day today
we're going to be talking about how do
we achieve that future and through the
strength of culture and Leadership and I
have to say I was really reflecting
um yesterday I joined Four Seasons
January 2025 minutes before the pandemic
started and so that was a really
interesting time for me and in my own
leadership and what a what a crash
course in the culture of Four Seasons it
was something I'd never ever seen or
experienced before
honestly it will go down in a chapter of
Four Seasons that even through the most
traumatic most difficult time in this
company's history are people and our
leadership
supported each other supported our
guests supported our community
communities it was just really really
remarkable and it wasn't even just like
Baseline support it was elevated support
and actually
what we accomplished in that time set us
up for where we are today we did we did
Crisis management and we did some things
that really set us up strategically so
just really remarkable and a testament
to the leadership of each and every one
of you in the room it is just truly
truly impressive
um so looking to the future we have a
real opportunity to amplify purpose that
we talked about yesterday we have an
opportunity to evolve our leadership
evolve our culture and today is a bit of
a focus around that it's going to have a
bit of a different feel than it did
yesterday we're going to spend some time
uh reflecting we're going to be spending
some time going inwards we're going to
do a little bit of self-development so
it will feel a little bit different than
it did yesterday we are super excited we
have two phenomenal world-class speakers
that are going to be joining us I mean
I'm just blown away that we have them
here to be able to talk to us about
culture about purpose about leadership
so it's going to be really fun and
engaging and different than yesterday
and I promise your feet well don't hurt
as much and so
I had to change my shoes
so Christian and I are super super
excited about kicking off today and with
that I am going to turn it over to
Christian
no no you go first
all right thank you
[Music]
thank you for being here
so this is super exciting because
um I'm not going to introduce Simon
because everybody knows who Simon is
but it's super exciting because Simon
has not done this since the beginning of
the pandemic and he will probably not do
this again because he's stopped doing
public engagements in terms of speaking
and he can probably explain why but he
did this because
um
he loves us he loves you guys he loves
Richard he loves the company
and I will tell a story because it's a
it's a story that I think is relevant
of how we met so we met do you remember
when he did the pub down in Miami during
art puzzle some of you were involved and
were there it was a cool event and we
invited
David Copperfield to come Sarah Cyrus
there sorry I invited David Copperfield
and it was like a David cup look okay
great and then
David invited
Simon to join
so Simon comes with David coming you
know putting his shirt down and he's
coming through the boat and everybody's
every time somebody would come up
towards him he'd be ready to to you know
put his hand out to shake and people go
to some and say
good that you're here and David cuppy
will be standing there like
you know I mean I was the one who was
invited I should have never invited him
you know but needless to say you're a
bit of a kind of rock star at Four
Seasons as well and we're lucky because
we had um we had the opportunity of Mr
and Mrs sharp with us last night and Mr
Mr sharp is a rock star in the company
as well so we got two rock stars now
that's great
um it's
a Lollapalooza yeah so super proud as
I've told you we spend uh yesterday all
day reconnect it's the first time
reconnect in five years yeah
um and uh and as you know there's been a
bit of a disruption over the past couple
years uh to say the least no travel so I
know you just you just got here right
and it's one of the first International
trips you've done in a in a while so how
did that feel yeah this is the second
international trip I've taken uh since
pre-covered since 2019.
um I still keep saying last year in mean
2019.
um uh uh the first one I went to London
and uh Paris and Stockholm and I got
covered in Stockholm those bastards
um uh uh but this trip has been has been
wonderful as well it's wonderful it's
nice to be it's nice to be on the road
again it's I mean not not for work it's
nice to be traveling again is what I
mean
and
I mean you the process of traveling and
getting to a hotel like this
anything change in your perception
versus prior to to covet
[Music]
um
I mean you know some people I I have to
say I love wearing masks I think it's
the best thing in the world uh it's like
oh yeah I love it I wear I wore masks on
my flights I I think it's the best thing
in the world uh it's nothing to do with
covid it's I don't want your cold I
don't want your cough I don't want your
flu you know I've gotten sick so many
times being on planes that now that the
sort of social Acceptance in the west to
wear a mask you know you have to
consider the difference between the East
and the West the East if you're sick you
wear a mask to prevent other people from
getting sick in the west we were mad we
wear masks to prevent getting sick from
you you know uh I mean I think the East
has something figured out that we don't
this is sort of public service but
anyway I I still love I I yeah I'm all
about it
I think you should join our lead with
care yeah program Dr zenderman is going
to be very happy to meet you
yeah I'm big into service if you're a
sick wear mask I think it's a great idea
so obviously the
the the uh the pandemic of the past two
years has been uh
obviously a huge disrupture hospital has
been impacted
more than many other Industries as you
know uh and this team here has done an
incredible job you know not only
surviving but really thriving uh through
it
um but from a leadership skills
perspective from you know how you lead
people
post pandemic what do you think are some
of the big shifts and big changes that
we have to adjust to As Leaders as we
lead our teams when when covet hit it
was fun to sit back and watch the
leadership reactions
um of organizations and it was inspiring
to see that whether people were good
leaders or bad leaders where they were
effective or ineffective prior to covid
they all most of them lean back on their
own Humanity you know where it was
normal for people to pick up the phone
and say are you okay is your family okay
we had more patience you know if
somebody was struggling and their kids
were struggling or had a sick family
member we we were okay you know we sort
of allowed them to take time and and for
me the the joy in that was that's just
good leadership you know it's a shame
that it took a pandemic for people to
learn how to care about each other and I
really hope that those skills that
people use naturally uh continue after
covet sadly I'm sure a lot of them will
will forget
and uh
you know a lot of it's just what I
consider good leadership I uh ideals
happened organically so another one was
I talk about this idea of the uh the um
the worthy rival
so I don't believe in the sense of
competition you know we live in a world
where there's no such thing as winning
business it doesn't exist right
um uh where two organizations who sell
basically the same product for basically
the same price basically the same
quality can both be wildly successful
simultaneously you know there's no
winning and so when companies talk about
their competition to me it doesn't make
sense because competition a competitor
is another player you want to try and
beat which means you spend too much time
focusing on what they're doing
and you spend too much time comparing
arbitrary metrics whether it's profits
or revenues or market share or a number
of properties or number of employees or
number whatever it is they're arbitrary
you get to pick what you're making the
comparison and you're all proud of
yourself when you win at the end of the
year but the game doesn't end
um I prefer the concept of a worthy
rival
and a worthy rival is another
they may they may or may not be in your
industry but it's another player in the
game who does one or many things better
than you
in other words their strengths reveal to
you your weaknesses
and you can study them you can be
grateful for them but try and competing
against them is is pointless
um but the whole idea is that the the
only true competitor in the game of
business is yourself how do we improve
what we're doing and learn from those
who do similar things to us rather than
trying to beat them and one of the
things that I saw in kovitz struck which
I found so fascinating is everybody was
so preoccupied with their own Survival
that the total number of companies that
had any kind of presentation about our
competitive threats was Zero nobody was
worried about their competitors because
they were just trying to survive well
that's correct that is the right
mentality in a good Market or a bad
Market which is uh how do we even if
times are good how do we survive for 50
100 150 years rather than how do we
maximize this year and then and then
blow all the wealth at the end of the
year you know
um uh so I I that some of those things
that kovid sort of revealed are really
good leadership skills that I hope I
hope
stay Way Beyond kobit yeah
and so what are some of the you know uh
what are some of the change that we that
companies need to make to have this more
this less competitive approach and more
I guess it's what you write about in the
infinite infinite game right yeah yeah
what what does that look like like how
does a leadership team like this think
about well how do we focus on what what
we can do better versus how we can beat
our company right well as I said before
like pick you can it's you can pick your
unworthy Rivals
um you can pick any company for any
reason and say they're better than us
you know what can we learn from them
um I'll give you a real life story that
really captured this for me
um and it's it's
um it's in the book but I'll tell it to
you
um uh
I spoke at a
uh education Summit for Microsoft
and then a few months later I was
invited to speak at an education Summit
for Apple
at the Microsoft Summit this back in
Steve Ballmer days
um in the Microsoft Summit
um the vast majority of the
presentations by the executives spent
most of their time talking about how to
beat Apple
at the Apple Summit 100 of the
presentations were how to help teachers
teach and how to help students learn
one was obsessed with beating their
competition the other one was obsessed
with advancing their mission
um at the end of my talk at Microsoft
they gave me a gift
they gave me the Zune when it was a
thing this was Microsoft's response to
the iPod
and this little piece of technology I
have to say was really very very good it
was quite a good little piece of
technology it didn't work on an Apple so
I couldn't use it that's a different
problem but it was it was very good so
at the end of my Apple talk I was
sharing a taxi with an apple executive
and I couldn't help myself I just had to
stir the pot
and I turned him I go you know Microsoft
gave me their new Zune and it is so much
better than my iPod Touch
and he turned to me and he said I have
no doubt
and the conversation was over
[Laughter]
because he understood this was an
infinite minded organization he
understood
that sometimes
the your competitor will do something
better than you and sometimes you'll be
better than them there's no such thing
as winning or losing there's only a head
in behind and where Microsoft was
obsessed with beating apple apple was
obsessed without doing itself
and so the great irony is just a couple
years after that Apple released the iPod
the iPhone
so where Microsoft was obsessing with
how to make a better iPod Apple was on
to the next thing didn't even care and
that's the whole idea which is
absolutely study and learn from the
other players you see I don't even call
them competitors the other players in
your industry see what they're doing
better like I said it reveals your
weaknesses and say we can do better than
than ourselves grow eventually they no
longer become worthy of comparison
anymore because you you advance
yourselves but the whole idea is Apple
was thinking about what they could do
next not how they could beat Microsoft
to get more market share for an iPod
so learn from others and how you can be
better absolutely like I said their
strengths reveal to your weaknesses and
that's a gift
so let's switch topic um and we're
amongst friends here so we can be fully
transparent so one of the areas of
opportunity that we have when we look at
our Employee Engagement service is and
it's surprising to me because because of
our culture is Trust
and especially at the mid monitoring
level and uh and you know we had
conversation about this but you talk a
lot about trust and the importance of
trust within organizations and I think
that you know I'm super proud of you
know the culture that we have that goes
way back Mr Sharp was talking about you
know the Golden Rule well before anybody
wrote about you know company cultures
um I think we also very genuine as a
company as Leaders
um and yet here we have this opportunity
right especially with our
um kind of you know hourly line
employers
any advice first in terms of uh you know
what what we could think about doing
differently
so we have to remember trust as a
Feeling
right uh it's not a it's not a command
or an order they trust me it doesn't
work trust me it's like a used car
dealer uh
um uh
it's a feeling and that feeling comes
from people feeling psychologically safe
um you know I use the story of Noah to
help tell this which is you know
managers not just his managers stop by
to say are you okay is there anything
you need on a regular basis and he said
it himself versus Caesar's Palace he
says only at the Four Seasons do I feel
I can be myself
his Charming funny you know uh quirky
self
that the Four Seasons the one of the
things that I love about you is you know
when you get into the luxury Hospitality
it it it it starts to feel like putting
on white gloves
and it starts to feel
um tight you know and your definition of
luxury is the opposite which is it's
much more human and you allow for people
not to follow a script but you allow
them to be themselves and interpret what
it means to care their own way which I
absolutely love
um the hardest part about it and and
this this uh this time is more difficult
now than ever before because people are
psychologically burnt out
uh people are exhausted people are
uncertain anxiety is an all-time high
and young people who are coming into the
workforce who've never really had a job
before you know they
they have an expectation that is
almost impossible to reach so for
example if you go back to like the 1950s
the 1960s
um you know we got our sense of purpose
from church we got our sense of
community from bowling league we got our
sense of we had we had barbecues on the
weekends with our neighbors
um and work was loyal to us and we were
loyal to work we worked there until we
got a gold watch
um and you know but it but work was
primarily a place that we we got money
to pay our bills
um there's an entire Generation Now who
when I talk about the gold watch they
don't know what I'm talking about like
there is no such thing anymore between
loyalty from a company or a loyalty to a
company and we can thank Jack Welch for
that
um for you know 30 years of of
destroying that kind of uh that kind of
thinking
it's true I've made it my career to undo
everything he did
um um and and now you know uh attendance
church attendance is way down
there's no such thing as bowling leagues
anymore
we don't really know who our neighbors
are
and so we're looking to work to provide
all these things for us we're looking to
work that you have to give me a sense of
purpose you have to give me a sense of
community this is where my social life
has to be
now you have to agree with all of my
Politics as well
and the newest one that's really since
covid
um you have to be my place for therapy
as well right and much like the
unreasonable expectations people are
putting on romantic Partners like no one
can live up to the standard that you're
hoping for me I think that the standard
that especially young people are putting
on the expectations on a place of
employment on a work family are are
impossible for any company to meet
and we've seen it in our company and
I've seen it in other companies as well
where for example and again particularly
young people but not exclusively
um
because the stress is high and remember
the way work used to work and it's
slightly different for you because it's
still mostly in person but the way work
used to work which is you go to work
and then after work you go out with your
friends and you complain about work
right which is totally healthy which is
totally healthy by the way you know
bitching and moaning about your boss is
totally fine and that that venting is
totally fine right you have a safe space
to let it out
but we didn't get the opportunity to go
out with our friends that was taken away
from us right and so we went to work
whether in your business in person or or
but then we didn't
go to the the bar or the pub afterwards
or we didn't go out for dinner
afterwards we had no outlet for the
stress and so we did was because we're
spending most of our time with people
from work we talk to people at work
and so now you have you have an increase
of venting at work you know beyond the
usual amount and especially if you're in
a virtual environment uh uh uh negative
narratives or false narratives can swirl
up like crazy
um and worse
young people in particular but not
exclusively would find the one or two
empathetic ears that they worked with
and they would unload all of their
problems not just complaining about work
and my boss but you know I I my my
relationship is struggling I'm
struggling with my parents I'm uncertain
about the future the war in Ukraine you
know George Floyd it's like
on one person venting
uh because that person is empathetic and
listens and takes it all in but the
problem is is that person is now taking
on everybody's stress and so you have
people who are burnt out not from work
they're burnt out because they have
overloaded by everybody else's problems
now because we're expecting work to be
our therapy
um and so we are in a peer and I and the
the the good news is we can we can see
some of the patterns the bad news is
I think we're in such a period of
incredible flux
that what the future of work looks like
is still so uncertain like what does it
mean to have a full-time job
like we saw this in covid you know I'm
doing my work nobody cares if I start at
10 or go to eight or work random hours
you know go to the vet in the middle you
know no nobody's really it's okay so
I'll take a second full-time job
and you know why can't if I'm not
letting anybody down and I'm able to
maintain the pace
why can't I do that and one employer
will say well you can't do that because
we pay your benefits you're full time
with us but who says like so the
definition of full-time employment is up
is up for grabs
right
um I think people are demanding it
you've talked about this people are
demanding more flexibility because they
had it
you know like the the Pandora's Box is
open no putting the genie back in the
bottle
um uh
uh and so what is the definition of of a
full-time job is up in in is up in the
is is up for grabs I think these things
are unresolved and I think there's an
opportunity for any company but a
company like yours is to start to Define
these things so that other organizations
can learn from you
um because the best organizations we
will copy them
and you know just by way of example the
way Airbnb handled its layoffs they did
they laid off ten percent of their
employees during covid
um and the way that they handle it was
absolutely exquisite
right you're doing something traumatic
and
um they were very generous with their
packages more generous than uh I know
some of the behind the scenes it was
chesky branchesky this year who pushed
for the company to be more generous
but the thing that I found most
impressive was the day that the layoffs
went into effect
that day a website went up airbnb.com
Talent where they put everybody's resume
online
in a central Hub to help them find
employment so they didn't just let them
go and give them money they set them up
to help them find employment and by the
way we rated that website as well
we needed online Talent we needed
programmers we needed those things we
went straight to airbnb.com Talent the
fact that they did that was brilliant
because it shows that we care and treat
you with dignity even if we have to do
the awful thing of as of asking you to
find employment somewhere else we're
going to try our best to and and others
will copy them that's what I mean about
about setting an example that others
will copy
that was an amazing answer wow
I learned a thing or two in here right
you like that
you it was worth the trip you you we
could step right here and we'll be well
ahead of where we started well I
you're giving me too much credit because
I didn't answer your question that's
okay I'm used to that you're not a very
good listener but you are a good talker
I have I have a I have a a
a long list of failed relationships that
would agree with you
um uh
you are in a very difficult and
uncomfortable position
because I think leadership is more
difficult now than it has ever been
because you're dealing with you dealing
with human anxiety you're dealing with
human uncertainty you're dealing with
human ambition and human Egos and and
again especially young people who think
they know what they want and don't who
have certainty and are very outspoken
and do not mind going around their
boss's boss to come to you
you know so you're going to be dealing
with a 19 year old saying why am I not
given this and you're like I don't where
are where do you work you know
um
uh they have no fear
of doing that they also have no fear of
quitting
and so we've seen this pattern where
remember they're very they're as a Young
Generation they're actually less
equipped to deal with stress than
previous generations
uh and and so anxiety is high and
they're very confrontation avoidant
so for example we've seen this where
they feel like they deserve a raise
and they don't know how to ask for a
raise
and so instead of asking for raise
they'll just quit
and then sometimes with an email that
says you don't value me you don't pay me
enough you're like you just had we just
had to ask the answer we love you you
know
so they're not afraid of quitting but
they are afraid of asking for things or
if they do ask for things that sometimes
crumbs across very aggressive or
accidentally black and white like I've
been here
um eight months and I would like a 50
raise
and I'm not exaggerating I mean you've
you know and and uh and the problem is
that they're ill-equipped what they're
doing is they're they're putting you in
a yes or no position
so even if you say here's the plan to
get you that over the course of the next
eight months
they take it as a no
because I asked for something black and
white and so one of the things I think
there's a huge opportunity for a company
is to help people to build in training
that helps them uh with their human
skills I hate the term soft skills
please let's never use that term again
you know we talk about hard skills and
soft skills those things are opposite
hard and soft are opposites they're hard
skills the skills you need to do your
job and human skills the skills you need
to be a better human being and we want
you to excel at both and we're going to
train you to do both
and some of the human skills that are
underappreciated and under trained in
this day and age
are how to have difficult conversations
had of an effective confrontation how to
give and receive feedback
and I think we have to train those
things so that if we equip them with the
skills instead of saying I've been here
for eight months I want to raise to say
I've been here for eight months I really
love it here my goal is to stay here
I have
um Financial Ambitions can you help me
get on a path to get to this number now
we can have a conversation because it's
now a Continuum rather than a black and
white question but the point is is I
don't fault them they lack the skills
and so I think there's a huge
opportunity for an organization like
yours to teach these young people coping
mechanisms stress relief the biggest one
being how to ask for help that is the
single biggest thing that is lacking at
every generation
which is I am struggling can you help me
whether it's personal or professional
that is absolutely lacking and so we do
unhealthy things to help compensate
social media and other things
interesting that can also inform our
Learning and Development platform
obviously
um okay we're going to switch topic
again and I wanted to make sure we have
some time for Q a but those are
important uh important topics and I
don't want to stop you because you're
obviously very insightful on on any type
of stream again so diversity inclusion
and belonging topics something that um
I think we're uh you know if I were
politically correct I would tell you oh
yeah we've made great progress and we're
working really hard on it and we have a
great plan yeah the truth is you know
you just look around the room and the
reality is I think we have a long way to
go yep
um and it's not for lack of caring
or uh I think it's it matters to all of
us we also have a company where we
promote from within heavily because
um you know that's how we got to where
we are today yeah and so
um what are others doing there's many
companies that are face the same reality
that we do what are other doings that to
your point earlier that we can learn
from not competitors yeah yeah but what
was it uh worthy Rivals worthy Rivals
yeah that are doing that that you say
hey look at that you know this could be
a good uh good direction well I think
most importantly and you seem to be
doing this most importantly is you see
it as a journey rather than event I
think the companies that are doing it
wrong view it as an event which is we
have this issue we're not as diverse as
we need to be and so let's fix that flip
a switch you know go in a hiring binge
ta-da right
um and the problem is it's it's that's
not how that's not how it works which is
this is a journey of of making our
organization more representative of the
general population and to say we have to
do better just being just acknowledging
that you're that you there is room for
improvement I think is a big part of it
um but obviously
um um where are you looking to hire who
are you asking to to to make
recommendations
um uh uh all of these things matter I
mean it's literally just opening the
opening the the aperture one of the
things we have to recognize is we all
have an inherent bias which is we we
look for people who look like us you
know and and to stop doing that
um also go to other companies ask them
who's really good
um but the the fact that you're treating
is a journey that you will never
actually the point is you'll never
actually be perfect it's going to be a
striving for the rest of time
you know
um uh because it's there's three words
there it's diversity inclusion and
belonging belonging comes from your
values and your and your purpose
um diversity comes from what it looked
like but inclusion is how people feel
yeah so it's one thing to hire somebody
but do they feel like they're valued and
included and part of the organization so
all of those are strivings none of those
you'll ever be perfect at none of those
you'll ever complete
um but it is it is a game of constant
Improvement
so now I'd like to talk about something
that you probably don't know much about
but it's okay I've still asked you a
question
um the purpose and why
um so we just you know we we uh we have
in this journey where we've had this
amazing culture
based on the Golden Rule which is all
about how we behave and and and then we
have been thank you
um we've thought about the impact that
this can have on the world and we have
uh socialized our purpose which I think
resonated with everybody in the room and
even resonate with Mr Sharp
um and it was interesting because I when
you know Anna and I mentioned it to you
because obviously we wanted to get your
perspective you had nothing to say you
were like
that's good
and I think it's unusual for me which is
unusual because normally you destroy
everybody so
um I mean in a nice way
so this is coming from the Air Force
see
Antoine it was not a compliment
that's good
all right
um so what what about it resonated and
what did you feel it was it was a good
purpose so
um I mean I have a bias with the word
inspire inspire you know
um
to me to to make that an action rather
than a result you know to inspire I love
that which is you think how to it's it's
a it's a it's a standard by which you
have to live by right did you inspire
someone today yeah you know
um I have a thing I I I've abandoned it
lately but I had
um two fish bowls in my room
and we can calculate you know we know
the average lifespan we know our average
lifespan it's you know whatever the
number is 78 or whatever it is so you
can actually easily calculate the number
of
months weeks or days that you
statistically have left on this planet
right
um and so I bought a bag of marbles and
one marble represented each week that I
have left on the planet
and I filled up the exact number based
on the statistics in one fishbowl
and at the end it's it's more it's more
inspiring than Doomsday
uh I mean it's just statistics yeah no
no but at the end of every week I would
ask myself
um I actually got it down to the day but
at the end of every week I'd say was
this a week worth living did I do
something to inspire someone
and it's my own standard and if the
answer is yes I move it to the other
Fishbowl ifian says no I throw away the
marble because I wasted it
right
um and uh and that's why I love the word
inspire I believe it is a standard to
live by and inspiration is what how we
make other people feel
you know it's not did you do something I
did something good today I gave money to
charity that's not what it is it's how
did I make someone feel and did they
feel
that their their life is even better
even for five minutes because of
something because of their interaction
with me right
um and then genuine care I think is the
second part of it right yeah
Inspire the world
to lead with genuine heart right with
genuine heart and again I think that
sets you up for values like you know and
it's proprietary I've never heard
anybody talk about genuine people talk
about Innovation and you know Integrity
like those are generic words
but genuine heart is something you can
own and so how do you amplify a genuine
heart
um what are the standards of of of
leading with genuine heart what does it
mean to lead with General heart what are
the values that mean that are you giving
out a genuine heart award you know to
the person in each property who
exemplifies and by the way the way to do
that is to ask their teammates to vote
for them not come from leadership
like who who inspires us to leave with
genuine heart to the degree that we want
to be more like our own colleague
because a peer review is actually more
powerful than than a review from from uh
from up on high because really we're
working for one person's approval where
a peer review is my team loves me and
we're not angry when somebody wins that
award I deserve that because I voted for
him because I voted for him right
um
um and it sets a standard for the rest
of the team so so I think uh peer review
where we allow our own people to choose
who within our group who within our team
has inspired us to lead with genuine
heart and the irony is they may not be
your best individual performer
but they're probably your best natural
leaders
it doesn't necessarily always line up
with with performance
very good
very nice
um
the other thing
again I do like the fact that it's about
Inspire the world not Four Seasons to
your point about the infinite game and
wanting to raise the bar for everybody
correct so I think it also calls out to
you know to really Elevate the
conversation and encourage others yeah I
mean you play the infinite game for the
good of the game right right which is
you're in the hospitality industry for
the good of the hospitality industry and
for the good of all business and the
best companies the ones we love and
admire right they share
you know it's it's the ones who are
protective you know of what they've
because they think it's a competitive
advantage and what they don't what they
fail to recognize is implementation is
the competitive Advantage not the idea
itself
execution is the competitive Advantage
but the ability to share the things you
believe in and the things you uh uh have
figured out yeah for the good of
business because we don't just believe
your employees should be treated well we
believe all employees should be treated
well you know and if we if you figured
things out so I'll tell you a story so
Bob Chapman is the CEO of a company
called Barry waymiller it's a company
I've written and spoken about quite a
lot especially in my book uh Leaders Eat
Last okay
um and you had the opportunity to meet
Bob Bob is one of those unique
remarkable leaders and the way I met Bob
is he'd read start with why and he sent
me a letter and saying I'm building the
kind of company that you've written
about
and I said I want to meet you and so we
had lunch in Los Angeles this Famous
Lunch
um where we were scheduled for an hour
and we both cleared our schedules and
spent the next three hours together
because we loved each other
and I didn't believe him I said you know
I talk about an ideal it's not realistic
it's a it's a striving
he says no no I have it I said well I
want to see it to believe it so he
picked me up in his plane from New York
and we flew we spent three days flying
around the country to all these
different factories and it's a
manufacturing company right this is blue
color some Union some non-union
manufacturing right
and what I saw absolutely astonished me
it blew me away I've never seen anything
like it
um and he didn't prepare anything he let
me roam the factory floor without any I
could talk to anybody I could ask
anybody any question I wanted
there was no window dressing and I was
absolutely blown away and I'll just tell
you one quick story that really
exemplifies uh and this one's I haven't
written or spoken about this one so this
one was I haven't talked about this one
so they have a machine that was getting
old you know this is a factory big
machine yeah
um that's getting old and need to be
replaced traditionally how large
machines are replaced is somebody in
procurement
fills out a list of requirements and
then goes in the market to find a
machine that fits a budget right that's
usually how it's done that's not how
they did it they went to the factory
floor to the two guys who work on that
machine one who's pretty young in his
early 20s one who's got more experience
uh neither of them have college
educations I think one had a GED
um and they said to them you need to
replace your machine you have a budget
of 750 000 go
and these two guys travel around the
country looking at I never came back
exactly
they now live in Tahiti uh they they uh
uh they gave him a budget not the money
uh that was smart uh they flew around
the country they they looked at new and
used machines and the people selling
machines said they've never seen
anything like it they've never had
anybody show up in overalls climbing in
the machine usually it's a guy in a suit
showing up with a clipboard right you
know they ended up spending 650 000 so
they were really excited that they saved
the company money and that's their
machine right that's that I can
guarantee that machine will never break
down right and the trust and it makes
perfect sense but this is what one of
the things that Bob says you know Bob
says is
we trust people who have college
educations who work in a back office and
we don't trust people who don't have
college educations what about their
education makes them trust where they're
untrustworthy he says I know some pretty
dishonest mbas you know uh
um and that's one of the things that Bob
did but the point was is we I went on
this wonderful tour with Bob and then we
finally went back to their corporate
headquarters in St Louis and the team
that had sort of built this culture was
sitting around a table and they were all
looking at me like this going isn't this
amazing like we built what you what you
wrote about
and I sat there and I said
I think you're the most selfish
organization I've ever met in my entire
life and they always sort of stunned
that I would say that I said look I
think it's amazing what you've built I
think it's absolutely incredible but how
selfish of you that you only offer this
thing this kind of thing that you've
built for 6 000 people what about the
millions of people who hate their jobs
who don't want to go to work every day
what are you doing for them
and it was on it was from that
conversation that Bob
open the doors they now offer training
they now for tours like Bob now he wrote
a book about it you know he's now in the
speaking circuit yeah he's out there
he's now a public figure
and he's promoting this new way of
leading in this new way of thinking
and that's what I think you have an
opportunity to do as well which is
amazing what you do for your people but
think about all the things that you have
innovated that would benefit other
companies and other people that you can
share again the competitive Advantage
comes in the execution and the fact that
you're the leader the brand is the lead
right you know think about Apple had a
small had a four percent market share
for computer operating systems Microsoft
had 96 and yet Microsoft followed Apple
Right leader doesn't mean biggest
doesn't mean biggest market share
doesn't mean most profitable you know
although in this case it does
leaders results in it yeah but it's
definitely not market share revenues
Right leader means other people follow
what you do
and if your brand stands for something
that people want to copy
and you're leading the way then clearly
you are competing against yourself and
not them but let them compete against
you
um and I think that the Four Seasons is
one of those Brands and I can't think of
anyone in the hospitality who has ever
done that who's ever reached outside of
their own
uh industry that others want to be more
like them
um can I ask myself a question please if
anybody thinks I'm in control here this
is just a joke right
it's fake so so uh which leads the which
leads to a good follow-up question
please ask yourself
because I have no idea what you're
talking about which is which is if
indeed we are to lead others and step
outside our own industry how do we
innovate that how do we do that
I'm glad you asked
great question
okay
you absolutely have a challenge and it
is a difficult one right
um
which is you're not a new company
in a world that is now digital and
uh
and data driven
so let's think about Innovation
Innovation for two seconds
for millennia
Innovation predominantly meant Hardware
right
I made a bit of printing press now the
printing press that we have today is
basically the same thing that Gutenberg
did it's a thing that goes like this it
goes fast or sure but it's basically the
same thing right
the airplane is basically the same
physics right it's 100 the same physics
um but for for for for for many many
many years Innovation meant hardware and
Hardware is very expensive which is why
the only uh organizations that could
innovate were governments and large
companies right because you could afford
to
the computer and the internet completely
changed that
um the the invention of the personal
computer and Steve Wozniak one of the
founders of Apple talked about this he
says I imagine a day in which an
individual could compete against a
corporation the computer allows that
where literally one person can compete
against a company that's incredible
and the speed at which innovation can
happen because innovation in the
hardware model is slow and expensive in
the software model it's fast and cheap
right so think of your iPhone
the hardware is very expensive it's over
a thousand dollars which is insane and
when they release it it actually has
software on it that is imperfect and
they know it's imperfect but they give
it to you anyway and then very quickly
they start fixing it and the patches
start coming out right and sometimes
it's minor you don't even see the
difference and sometimes it's major you
get a major overhaul and eventually the
software gets too big
that the hardware can no longer contain
it and then you have to buy a new piece
of expensive Hardware
and this is the model that old companies
have to learn to embrace
and if you look at the companies that
are dominating right now whether it's
Netflix it's still big it's it's habits
issues but it's still big Netflix which
reinvented film and television Tesla
which is Reinventing cars Amazon which
is Reinventing uh uh retail
they're all new companies they're all
Facebook Google Tick Tock they're all
data companies the old style of big
innovation those companies aren't the
biggest companies anymore they used to
be but they're not the biggest companies
anymore it's data and it's because of
their speed at which they can make
change
and so the companies that are struggling
are the companies that are trying to
Simply add data to their Hardware model
so if we add a flat screen TV to our car
we're Innovative no no no Tesla built an
iPhone
Tesla built an iPhone on Wheels what
makes that car remarkable is not that
it's an electric car it's that my 2002
Tesla and my friends 2019 Tesla do the
exact same things because the car can
update itself
we have all the same features it's not
the old way where yeah I don't have
those features I have the the I have
last year's model
right that's gone
and if you look at the companies that
are challenging and pushing
um uh uh you know take a look at um if I
did this just for comparison's sake I
went on Robinhood they apt to make
investments and I did fidelity right
Fidelity looks like it's a bunch of old
Finance people who said oh I guess we
have to make a website
try to make a trade on there and I kid
you not first of all they locked me out
for some reason I couldn't understand so
I was on customer service for half an
hour finally when I got in it took me
about 45 minutes to figure out how to
make a trade so over an hour for me to
make a trade
Robin Hood downloaded the app in five
minutes I was done
the user experience was astonishing and
the reason is is because Fidelity is a
financial company that's attempting to
go online
and Robinhood is a technical is a is a
tech company that happens to be
in finance
your challenges you're a bricks and
mortar company that's attempting to go
into Data
what if you were to invent what if you
were to start Four Seasons from scratch
today what if you were a data company
that happened to be
in hospitality
right and when you start thinking that
way all of a sudden the ideas start
flowing right so I'll just give you a
few examples
um that again just off the top of my
head when you start thinking this way
which is
do you track
everything
about your guests
right like everything they ordered in
every one of your hotels everything they
drank or ate out of the mini bar
not that you would use that data you
know a you never sell it because that's
your values you're using to improve the
experience legitimately you know it's
not what they tell you right
um
um and imagine that for your you you
wouldn't want to do this for one guest
but you know imagine you start to see a
trend that this guest they have a long
Trend they always have Coca-Cola and a
bag of nuts out of the mini bar every
time
right so you add more Coca-Cola more
Coca-Cola and more nuts in the mini bar
and maybe even leave one out from when
they arrive
it's about listening and you use the
data you're really good at listening
right your your people are good at
listening but now you're using data to
listen or
um
and you and I talked about you said this
that your goal is to get to charging
zero for the minibar I think you just
charge reasonable prices you know I
don't think you need to charge nothing
non-alcoholic products non-alcoholic
products yeah yeah uh it's just like
none of us likes to be gouged like 14
for a can of Coke and a bag of chips you
know just just make it reasonable yeah
and then nobody actually cares
um but all these little things learning
who's the the intense intense kind of
listening and then you ask yourself if
you have all of this data now what would
you innovate now at bricks and mortar or
planes or boats or whatever you're doing
would you build around
all of this information that you own
um and like I said what if you were to
start a hotel and hospitality company
what if you were to start a tech company
because you you know this Equinox is now
building hotels virgin is now building
hotels you know you have other people
outside you're coming in they're
leveraging their brand here so the
Christian Brands fashion brands how do
you leverage your brand to go there and
I think I think think of yourself as a
tech company that happens to be in
Hospitality not their way otherwise well
the great news is we have a phenomenal
new Chief commercial officer who's
sitting going in the room right here and
he's oh he's right in front of me and
he's his eyes must be going like because
this is exactly what we've been talking
about because the challenge you're going
to have is the same challenge as movies
as the same challenges television is the
same challenge as publishing which is
they said to themselves
we've been doing this business for 40
years 50 years I think we know what
we're doing yeah how do we add a flat
screen to to it how do we put data on it
the problem is
it's an entirely different animal it's
an entirely you cannot rely on your 30
years of experience which is very scary
when you have 30 years of experience
you literally have to throw it all out
so beginner's mindset
Natalie I think we're up right we're
done all right so sorry I know no
amazing are you kidding me that was
incredible so Simon Sonic Generations
okay
okay so let's do it we were giving a
little more time because this is great
thank you
um so why don't we I'm sure there's a
few questions in the audience that
people would like to ask Simon directly
yes
Hans
hi Simon
yep
a few tips or ideas from you on on
leadership in a virtual world so during
covet you know we all worked virtually
and and now yeah what's happening now
yeah and the office is five days a week
nine to six will probably never happen
again yep but then if you build a team
you you would like to have people around
you you would like to see them you talk
about inspiring inspiring via a zoom
call or a team skull not that easy so
what are your views on that sure so
there's there's there's multiple ways to
do it not all of them are healthy right
um uh remember the the the key word here
is flexibility I think flexibility is
here to stay
um I don't think we can predict exactly
what the future will look like but
flexibility for example it used to be
you asked permission that next week can
I work from home because my kids home
from school or something now you can
email in the morning saying hey I'm
going to work from home today and
everybody's fine with it that that's
here to stay so the key word is
flexibility how do you build flexibility
into the system
um companies that are dictating it I
think are struggling
um you must be at work
these days
um versus we would like you to come to
work two days a week
to maintain team culture and team you
know so you have to come to work two
days a week you can pick those days and
some days when we have Team meetings
then then everybody will come those days
but also easing into it I think one of
the things that a lot of companies that
have made mistakes is they went from
covid you know times to this is what
it's going to be on this date and I
think doing very very little bits over
time the only the companies that I've
seen make dictations they only did it
for senior leadership which I think was
actually very healthy which is for
senior leaders you must be at work
Monday Wednesday Friday or whatever days
you want right where Rank and file they
they made no dictates at all zero
because to a senior leader you can say
look you're a senior leader of this
company there are there are different
and higher expectations of you and we do
expect you to be at work on these days
but to but instead of making these
company-wide dictates to to start with
senior leadership let that let that get
a momentum for a few months and then if
you need to bring in other people you
can but I think the key is how do you
maintain flexibility while that uh while
you ask people to come back to work
great question tones
Charlie
thank you
um Simon it was great to hear
um about the um the insights about
loyalty of employees to to the employer
and how challenging that has become I
think we can all relate to that so maybe
um
some other thoughts on who's doing that
well to inspire or re-inspire the
Loyalty of employees to employers yeah
um it's a very good question and there's
unfortunately very few good answers
um uh we have to take a step back for a
minute right remember how young people
came up through work right which is
um
the damage that Jack Welch and that
model
did you know excessive uh uh
um weight on shareholder Supremacy
um you know judging people only by their
performance
um the idea of using mass layoffs on an
annualized basis to balance the books in
other words we're profitable just not as
profitable as we promise so you lose
your job right which is insane a
profitable company laying people off
right but this has become so normalized
that this young population has been
raised watching their parents and their
friends parents lose their job through
no fault of their own it's not a
meritocracy
and so why should they have loyalty to
the company they literally came up in an
age where they watched the company have
no loyalty to them
and so where people blame this young
generation for being disloyal or unloyal
I think I think they're responding to
the to the to the game that's been
that's been laid and so the question is
how do we demonstrate loyalty the
companies that I think do it well are
the ones that are excessive in their uh
um in their in their values and their
and their purpose but they're also
extremely honest that they're on a
journey one of the best examples and if
you saw the newspaper today about
Patagonia
um you know they are one of the
quintessential examples of people who
are there for the purpose and each and
all definitely lives it and the
decisions you can see that he makes
embody it but the company is also wholly
imperfect
and they talk about their imperfections
and they talk about the striving and I
don't think people I think the mistake
that a lot of companies make is
pretending that they've got everything
figured out when clearly we don't but if
they say that we don't understand this
or we got this wrong and here are the
lessons we learned and we know what to
do next time that level of honesty just
compare it to a personal relationship
you know you're not going to do well in
your marriage if you keep telling your
spouse I got everything right and I know
what I did wrong and don't worry like
you have to say I screwed up and here's
what I screwed up and here's what I've
learned and I think people are just
looking to feel that you're honest with
them one of the biggest things is is
quite weirdly is how we feel about our
own selves as well you know as Leaders
sometimes we think that we have to be
positive all the time so that our people
will be positive the problem is it
almost always backfires
I I was um young in my career and I had
one direct report her name was Cynthia
something made me look good every single
day I worked at a big Ad Agency and my
habit was to let Cynthia sit in on all
of my meetings if she was allowed to if
I could get her in just to learn even if
she had no responsibility and uh in the
meeting and we had a very we had a a
conference call with a senior client so
all the senior creatives all the senior
folks and and and I was a young
executive there and Cynthia sat on the
side just to listen and I invited her to
listen to him and the call went very
badly
and when we hung up the phone I vented
and I vented to my peers or my bosses
which I could do and I vented all this
anger at this client and then I look
over at Cynthia I went oh my God she
just heard me do that and as we walked
out of the office out of the conference
room I said to her I'm really sorry you
shouldn't have seen me vent like that I
apologize and she said no no no I'm so
glad she said you're always so positive
and yet I'm struggling on this client I
thought it was me
but the fact that you're you're
struggling as well makes me feel that
it's not me and it and it really
solidified our relationship and so for I
think for us as Leaders especially
coming off of covid for us to say
I'm having a hard week guys so I'm I may
not be as reliable this week I'm just
under a lot of stress a little bit from
home and a little bit from work so
please just be patient with me give
people permission to say to us I'm
having a bad week I'm struggling and we
get to say how can I help
but when we pretend that we've got
everything under control at all times
then we're forcing them to pretend that
they have they that they're under
control then we can't help them then we
can't lead with genuine heart
because we don't know
um I have a friend who's a general in
the Air Force the real Air Force and
uh and uh
and he he talks about mental health he
says if you break your leg you go see
the leg doctor if your head is broken
you see the head doctor he normalizes it
and he he leads by example he doesn't
just say hey if you're struggling go see
the go see the the shrink he'll say hey
guys it's been a rough week for me
um this between three and four I'm gonna
go see the counselor I'll see you later
he's and he's not doing it for show he's
doing it because he's he genuinely wants
to see the counselor but the point is
he's being very open about it and I
think for young people who want to see
us as human I think for us to reveal
those things I think is is a huge part
of it
it's great
[Applause]
yes
of course
sure
in a property sure how do we how do we
give some of that flexibility to those
folks that you know have to be on the
floor have to be at the property so ask
them
right take some of take some of your you
know who your best and brightest are you
know who the ones who who who who bleed
Four Seasons who love it here who care
you know who they are that you know it's
a bell curve you know everybody likes it
here but some people love it here take
the ones who love it here from the front
line you know you some of your your
servers or and say to them we want to
build more flexibility in the system
we know what we know from our 30 years
of experience but we want to know what
you would do so include them in the
conversation
um the and get and say give us options
of what a more flexible Workforce would
be like
you know don't let don't say you're
designing it because the problem is if
you don't implement it exactly as it was
asked for you know say give us input
that will help us make a decision ask
them
um let them help design it
um and then give constant uh status one
of the things that we're learning is
young people when when we ask them for
their opinions if we don't go back and
say we did this we did this they think
that we we feel unheard right so that
line of communication giving you an
update based on this thing that we said
we're doing here's where we stand
um and things that we're going to
implement that they suggest and not
going to implement to be very crystal
clear and give them feedback as to the
reasons why as a learning so it's not
arbitrary like yes no
um but I would I would go ask your
Frontline people if you would design the
perfect job in a flexible Workforce what
give us some feedback is what it could
look like
yeah I think we have time for one more
right side of the room sorry left side
somebody's raising their head back there
but I can't see oh there it is I'm here
yes hi hi
um I wanted to see your opinion on on
where people went I think when we came
out of covet we were
um we were thinking that people didn't
want to come back to hospitality but
then as you know we looked at other
companies you know there's a lack of
lawyers there is a lack of ambulance
drivers there's a lack of everything so
where do you think people went
and unemployment is a little all-time
low like everybody's quitting their jobs
and there's no jobs
and yet everybody's looking to hire
um
I think a lot of people are
there's a few ways to answer it first of
all
a lot of the jobs that people took
during covid we make the assumption that
they wanted to work for us when they
took the job during covid
in the reality is some people took the
job because it was a job during covid
and in their own minds it was never
supposed to be permanent you know maybe
some of them fell in love but they're as
soon as the market opened up their
intention was always to leave so we
can't completely beat ourselves up
um if if we do lose some people
um but I think a lot of people are
um they're bouncing they're they're
trying things
um I mean let's be realistic a lot of
young people move back home so their
bills are lower so they can afford to
wait and hang out
um I think the gig economy is a real
thing and what Uber and those companies
they built into the vernaculars idea of
a gig economy and I think people really
fancy being Freelancers
um maybe even freelance servers that I
work for three hotels because I want to
pick up shifts here that suit me beehive
and and and what does the gig economy
mean in traditional in traditional
employment I think that's a big part of
it to be honest
um but I think a lot of people are are
also recognizing that money is less
important to them than than the
relationships and their experiences and
I think people are okay making less
um so they may have cut or stabilized
their incomes and they they maybe don't
have that that crazy ambition the the
thing that I fear
and we touched upon this before which is
people are less afraid of quitting now
young people are less afraid of quitting
and they're building the gig economy
lives for themselves my fear is that
they're going to go from job to job to
job when we were younger you couldn't
quit a job in less than one year because
it would look bad on your resume right
now three months whatever goodbye
you know and my fear is Flash Forward
five years
one of two things will definitely happen
an employer will look at you that in
five years you've had nine jobs I'm not
going to hire you because I just can't
trust that you're going to stick around
or and you've had nine jobs in five
years you haven't been around anywhere
long enough to go through a cycle of
good times and bad times and so you have
no discernible skill set
and my fear is that what feels great now
it's it's it's going to have
consequences in a few years
um and um I'm worried about that and I
don't know how to communicate that in a
way that that is sticky
um you know I'm talking about eating
healthy now so you don't get diabetes in
20 years I mean you know it's it's hard
that's a hard message for people to
to statistic but I'm worried about that
that's great
that was amazing thank you so much
thank you
um
okay okay so we had said that you can't
take pictures with Simon or post the
pictures actually Simon is more than
happy to take a few pictures and you can
post them do whatever you want search
for me do you can't post whether you
film today but um but you can post
whatever you want so I don't know what's
coming up next Natalie I'm sorry I I was
so okay our hosts are here and um thank
you again yeah thanks for having me I
really appreciate it thank you thanks